La vague Omicron semble
s'essouffler aussi vite
qu'elle est arrivée.
Le point de Normand Grondin.
- Elle est brutale et explosive,
isisis tout indique que l'actuee
vague d'Omicron sera plus courte
que les vagues précédentes.
ALAIN LAMARRE,
expert en virologie, INRS
- Absolument, on l'a vu
à travers le mo
On a vu en Afrique du Sud
un pic très étroit, donc
une montée vertiusususe
et une descente aussi rapide.
- Plusieurs des premiers
pays touchés par Omicron
rapportent la même chose. En Aùu
tout a commencé, on enregistre
une chute rapide de 70 %
des cas. Au Royaume-Uni,
également durement touché,
une baisse de 14 %.
Et en France, on commence
à respirer un peu mieux.
OLIVIER VÉRAN, ministre
Solidarités et Santé, France
- On pourrait s'attendre à être
bientôt à une forme de pic.
Mais est-ce qutttt
un pic encore une fois
ou est-ce que c'est un plateau?
Ça, je ne peux pas vous
le dire aujourd'hui.
- Mê E E E États-Unis,
où les cas se comptent
par millions, les experts
En fait, si les vagues
précédentes mettaient, m m m m s
avant d'atteindre un sommet,
la vague Omicron y parvient
deux fois plus rapidement,
essentiellement en raisonde la é
exceptionnelle du variant.
- Un virus si contagieux qui
se répand très rapidement
dans la population,
bien, il va éventuellement
s'essouffler et manquer
sososososonnes à infecter.
- Le Québec, qui est frappé par
Omicron depuis la mi-décembre,
suivrait la même traje
- Il y a une confirmation
de la part des experts
que le nombre d'infectio
donc le nombre de cas,
se stabilise.
- C'est dans la région
de Montréal que la situation
devrait s'améliorer en premier.
BENOIT BARBEAU, spéc. virologie
sciences biologiques, UQAM
- Si vraiment Montréal
affiche cette tendance,
eh bien, on peut se réjouir.
Et au Québec, on pourrait
espérer, en effet, que
cette diminution-là va
commencer à être notable,
puis qu'on va se retrouver
dans les prochains jours,
semaines, à voir une diminution
qui est significative.
- Il faut rappeler
qu'il existe toujours un délai
entre la diminution du nombre
de cas et la baisse du nombre
d'hospitalisations.
Ici Normand Grondin